yeah that was this was a picture that we
did on the beach when we were shooting
in Miami for Baywatch it was from his
phone and it was just such a cool
looking picture that I wanted to post a
picture of him and I for his birthday it
was really funny because I had to ask
his people to give me the picture so I
can post it to wish him it was really
stupid actually
so there's this big debate that was
happening and the internet was trending
about my armpits who discusses armpits
so apparently they were tremendously
photoshopped or whatever that's what
people thought and I just found it
really funny so I decided to put a
picture up of my real armpits and see
what the world has to say I must be
doing something right if the entire
world is discussing my armpits it's cool
this was New York I had just landed and
I was starving and my it's my tradition
whenever I land into New York the first
thing I do is either get a hot dog or a
pizza I love street food and New York so
that's the first thing I did with a
giant hot dog with everything it's so
funny that you picked this picture
because this is actually GQ India and
yeah it was just oh I'm wearing my
fabulous shoes and laying down upside
down in a car cuz everyone does that you
know I was trying to make lying down
upside down in a car look casual
you see cheeky makes you do things like
that